the world is coming undone Imperial
flags rain across the galaxy
can you be trusted without your shackles
let's just get this over with shall we
with a mission for you a major weapons
test is imminent we need to know how to
destroy
is he really doing this I want to help
good
good
I've been recruiting through the
rebellion for a long time we destroyed
our aside the Empire now I fear nothing
all is as the force will see
the captain says you are a friend I will
not kill you
Thanks there isn't much time
every day they grow stronger
there was a ninety-seven point six
percent chance of failure
it means well
this is our chance to make real
difference
are you with me
all the way
you
Oh
it's like the fantasy you always have as
a kid everywhere as an amazing shot an
amazing character
it's about the humanity of it which just
makes the whole thing so real ready
Archer
your hearts beating and you're actually
in this situation you get something very
genuine that you can the plant you'll
actually compose shots that if we were
on a green screen set you just wouldn't
have known we're available pressure is
so high we're making a film that's right
touching my favorite movie of all time
but then if you're too respectful of it
that you didn't do anything new or
different take a risk then what are you
bringing to the table
we next we closed it down there
I mean this is really where film crew
like this really comes into their own
that kids when you were four years old
grew up with Star Wars figures it's a
bit like just being that kid again
may the force be with us
state your name for the record
Jen are so forgery of Imperial documents
possession of stolen property
aggravated assault resisting arrest on
your own from the age of 15
reckless aggressive and undisciplined
this is a rebellion isn't it
IRA bail we have a mission for you
the major weapons test is imminent we
need to know what it is how to destroy
it
is that clear yes what will you do
wouldn't catch you what will you do if
they break you
if you continue to fight
what will you become
can you be trusted without your shackles
let's just get this over with shall we
with a mission for you
a major